going back to the initial collaboration
seeing the trilogy from now 20 years
what do you think people want in their
20s and then 30s and then 40s you're
right to notice that it just keeps
changing and a people are different
I think what's the same is people's
desire to be loved to love to be
understood you want that to anybody at
any age but I think in that when you're
young it's all about the path ahead and
then you start to have walked a path you
know and there's start life and we like
to say or before sunrise is kind of
about what what could be and before
summarizes about what should be in
before midnight is that's what it is for
sunset sorry sunrise you know and so
these are different stages of life you
know what could be and when you're 30
it's like well should I shouldn't I
should have been the show and we give
you 40 see like okay this is yeah yeah
but you still have choices I mean life
your life is more and more carved by
your choices as you progress in life so
you know the third film is basically
even more cars than the truth first to
which is like you know they first meet
my accident on a train but they decide
to talk to each other and to get off the
train she decides to get off the train
then they decide second film she decides
to go at the book-reading and they
decide to hang out that day and he
decides to explain and so you get more
and more you know and and it gets one
more complex because there's more and
more decision to you mean